>> Laura: THE ATTENDEES IN
THAT QUAINT LITTLE TOWN IN
SWITZERLAND, THEY HAVE TO BE
VERY REASSURED ON THE
REALIZATION THAT NOTHING THAT
THEY ADVOCATE OR NO PANIC THAT
THEY INDUCE WHAT EVER HARM THEI
BOTTOM LINE.
>> WE NEED TO ACT TOGETHER TO
CLOSE TO FINISHING GAPS AND THA
MEANS TO FIGHT ARE PROGRESSIVEL
COAL AND SUPERCHARGE THE
RENEWABLE TO END THE ADDICTION
TO FOSSIL FUELS BERTH TO GET AL
THESE PROMISES IS LESSER YEARS
TO GET EMISSIONS EMISSIONS ARE
STILL GOING UP, WHEN WE GOING T
BRING THE EMISSIONS DOWN?
WE CANNOT LET THE OIL AND GAS
COMPANIES AND FEDERAL STATES
TELL US WHAT IS PERMISSIBLE?
>> HE IS LIKE HUMAN VERSION OF
THE HINDENBURG.
THESE PRONOUNCEMENTS FROM PEOPL
LIKE OR AND THE REST OF THE
BIGWIGS, THEY OFTENTIMES LEAD T
REAL POLICY PRONOUNCEMENTS AND
WE DON'T HAVE TO LOOK ANY
FURTHER THAN IN CALIFORNIA AT
THAT IS THE INCUBATOR FOR
LEFT-WING IDEAS AND IT HAS BEEN
THE LEADING STATE IN THE MOVE T
TRANSITION AWAY FROM FOSSIL
FUELS.
BUT WHAT ARE THE REPERCUSSIONS
OF THIS, THE COST?
ACCORDING TO A NEW REPORT ONE
THIRD OF OIL AND GAS WORKERS
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO EVEN FIND
OTHER JOBS AT ALL.
FOR THOSE THAT DO, NEARLY 30
PERCENT WILL EARN LESS
JOINING ME NOW IS MIKE ROWE HUS
OF HOW BUSINESS WORKS AND DIRTY
JOBS.
AS THE EXPERTS ON JOBS THAT
MAKES EVERYBODY'S LIFE EASIER,
YOUR REACTION TO THIS CALLOUS
AND DISMISSIVE ATTITUDE OF THE
ELITE OF JOBS THAT THEY DON'T
APPROVE OF?
IT IS HARD TO MAINTAIN A
CONSISTENT LEVEL OF OUTRAGE.
I HAVE BEEN AT THIS FOR 15 YEARS
, THE FOUNDATION I RUN IS
FOCUSED ON REAL JOBS THAT
REQUIRE AN ACTUAL SKILL THAT
TRULY EXISTS.
HONESTLY, WHEN I LOOK AT SOME O
THE COVERAGE OF DAVOS  I DON'T
KNOW WHY ANYBODY IS TAKING ANY
OF IT SERIOUSLY.
I WATCH IT YEAR AFTER YEAR.
THESE ARE VERY PEOPLE WHO FLY
PRIVATELY TO THIS RESORT TO
BASICALLY BLAME THE EVERYDAY GU
FOR ALL OF THE TROUBLE IN THE
WORLD.
I THINK MAY BE MY ANSWER IS I
JUST DON'T KNOW HOW A REASONABL
PERSON CAN SEE THROUGH THE
HYPOCRISY TO EVEN FOR A MOMENT
SERIOUSLY CONSIDER THE VALIDITY
OF ANYTHING YOU JUST PLAYED.
>> THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS JO
BIDEN AND HIS ENVIRONMENTAL TEA
ARE MOVING APACE.
THE KEYSTONE PIPELINE WAS
CANCELED.
WHEEZY OIL AND GAS PERMITTING A
RECORD STALL OUTSPREAD PEOPLE
REFUSING TO INVEST IN OIL AND
GAS BECAUSE OF THIS ESG AND
GREEN MOVEMENT.
WELL I AGREE WITH YOU THESE GUY
ARE TOTAL BLOWHARDS AND MANY OF
THEM TOTAL FRAUDS ON THIS ISSUE
THE POLICIES COME OUT OF THE
CORPORATE PUSH IN MANY CASES AN
IT'S NOT THE OTHER WAY AROUND
FOR THE CORPORATIONS ARE PUSHIN
FOR THIS QUOTE REVOLUTION
BECAUSE I THINK THEY'RE GOING T
MAKE A LOT OF MONEY EITHER WAY.
NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS THEY COM
OUT ON TOP.
>> I AGREE, IT'S KIND OF IN
UNHOLY ALLIANCE AND MOST BAD
IDEAS TAKE ON A CERTAIN KIND OF
INERTIA THAT GETS PUSHED AND
PULLED FROM A LOT OF DIFFERENT
PLACES.
SOMETIMES THINGS JUST HAVE TO G
SPLAT BEFORE THE REGULAR
MAJORITY WILL JUST END UP AND G
LOOK, IT'S FINE TO TALK ABOUT
RENEWABLES, IT IS WELL AND GOOD
AND I THINK IN OUR BEST INTERES
TO THINK IT OTHER WAYS TO AFFIR
THE PLANET, BUT TO AFFIRMATIVEL
MAKE FOSSIL FUELS THE ENEMY
RIGHT NOW AND TO MARGINALIZE AN
VILIFY THE VERY THING THAT WE
ARE ALSO COMPLETELY AND TOTALLY
RELIANT UPON, THAT IS A RECIPE
FOR CRAZY MAKING.
YOUR RIGHT, YOU CAN SEE IT
EVERYWHERE.
OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH ENERGY IS
DISCONNECTED.
A RELATIONSHIP WITH FOOD IS
WE'RE AT WAR WITH THE VERY
THINGS WE NEED, SO I WORKED ON
THE SHOWS I WORK ON BECAUSE IT
GIVES ME A CHANCE TO POINT TO
PEOPLE WHO I BELIEVE ARE
CONNECTED TO THE THINGS THAT
MATTER MOST, ENERGY AND FOOD.
WHAT'S GOING ON IN SWITZERLAND
RIGHT NOW?
I DON'T GET IT.
>> AND CALIFORNIA BY THE WAY,
WHERE THE STATE IS DESTROYING
AND OTHER CRITICAL INDUSTRY
WHICH IS INDEPENDENT TRUCKING.
THIS RECENT PIECE EXPLAINS WHIL
THAT GOVERNOR NEWSOM SIGNED IN
2014 TO SURRENDER THE COMPANIES
THAT THEY BUILT AND SEEK
EMPLOYMENT IN LARGE FIRMS THAT
CAN GO ON TO HIGHER THEM.
WHAT THE HECK KIND OF IMPACT
WILL THIS HAVE ON COST TO
AMERICANS?
TO GET THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I
MY VIEW IS MAY BE THE BIGGEST
UNREPORTED STORY AND THE COUNTR
RIGHT NOW.
85 IS THE ASSEMBLY BILL YOU ARE
REFERRING TO.
ITS BECOME LAW, NEWSOM SIGNED IT
.
WILLS WAYNE, WROTE THE ARTICLE
AND THE NATIONAL REVIEW AND I
HAD HIM ON MY PODCAST TO TALK
ABOUT IT BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST
TRUCKERS.
THIS STARTED WITH RIDESHARE.
LIFT.
IT HAS MOVED INTO ALL ASPECTS O
FREELANCE WORK IN THE GIG
ECONOMY AND IT IS COMPLETELY
UNDER FIRE.
THERE IS A TRACKER NAMED TOM
ODOM, HE CAME FROM NOTHING OUT
OF EAST LA.
HE BUILT A BUSINESS, HEAT NETS
CLOSE TO $200,000 A YEAR DRIVIN
HIS OWN TRUCK.
IT IS OVER FOR HIM.
IT IS GONE HE IS MOVING TO TEXA
IN 70,000 OF INDEPENDENT
TRUCKERS AND THIS STATE ARE
LOOKING AT THE END OF THE WAY
THEY WANT TO WORK.
IT IS GOING TO IMPACT EVERYTHIN
AND THE SUPPLY CHAIN, ANY BOOK
BUDDY WITH ANYTHING IN THEIR
HOUSE THAT WAS EVER ON A TRUCK
WILL BE IMPACTED BY THIS.
LOOK, MAYBE IT'S TOO LATE FOR
CALIFORNIA, BUT THERE IS AN ACT
IN CONGRESS RIGHT NOW TO TAKE
THIS THING NATIONWIDE AND PEOPL
NEED TO PAY ATTENTION TO THAT
FOR SURE.
>> THEY LIKE BIG, THEY DON'T
LIKE SMALL BUSINESS WHICH IS WH
SO MANY ENTREPRENEURS ARE
BECOMING POLITICALLY MORE
CONSERVATIVE.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY WHAT IS HAPPENING
.
THEY LOVE THE BIG CONGLOMERATES
AND THAT MEANS MORE CONNECTION
WITH THE GOVERNMENT.
MI